كما لو أن لبنان لم يكن لديه
مشاكل كافية بالفعل ،
يأتي نقص آخر في البنزين
فجأة ، فالبلد
بأكمله تعلم أنه قد دمر في غضون
شهرين ، وأنه من الصعب تحمل
العملة اللبنانية فقد فقدت 90 في المائة
من قيمتها في أقل من شهرين  سنوات
التضخم يرتفع بشدة انفجار هائل في
ميناء بيروت
أودى بحياة أكثر من 200 شخص العام الماضي
تسبب فيروس كورونا في مقتل آلاف آخرين ولم تكن البلاد قادرة على تشكيل
حكومة مناسبة في غضون عام تقريبًا.
موسيقى]
هذه الطوابير الطويلة خارج
محطات الوقود هي مظهر من
مظاهر مشكلة أكبر بكثير لحكومة
مفلسة مفلسة وليس لديها ما يكفي من
العملة
الصعبة لاستيراد الوقود لإبقاء الأضواء مضاءة
أيضًا بسبب نقص الإمداد بالوقود لإدارة
البلاد المتداعية
محطات توليد الطاقة ، يزداد انقطاع التيار الكهربائي المطول الطبيعي
لفترة أطول. أصبحت الشبكة الكهربائية
متقادمة
أولئك الذين يستطيعون تحمل تكاليفها يعتمدون على
المولدات الخاصة للتعويض  الفارق
الذي يزداد صرامة ، يحذر وزير الطاقة المؤقت في لبنان
ريموند من أن الأمور السيئة الآن
قد تكون لم يأت بعد ، سيكون انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
بمثابة تعتيم حقيقي وليس
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي العام سيكون
ظلامًا تامًا وأعتقد أن هذا
أنت تعلم أنها كارثة.  إنه ليس
سيناريو مناسب للعيش
، ورد أن العراق وعد بتقديم
وقود بسعر مخفض ،
لكنه لم يصل بعد ، وفي الوقت نفسه
لا يفعل السياسيون اللبنانيون المتشاجرون شيئًا لإصلاح مشاكل البلاد العديدة ،
لذلك نحن فقط نشتري الوقت أه
نركل العلبة.  طريق بلا
إصلاحات بدون حل كامل
للبائع ولبنان ينفد الوقت
والوقود ويبدو أن كل شيء آخر
بن ويتمان سي إن إن.